I just had a CT scan and a couple of questions, media style and chest wall,
Tyler area, right breast mass seed on prior exam measured this on today's
exam measured this so it's changed or on today's exam measured this on prior
exam so it's shrunk almost in half you know that's very good and then they give
an impression so whatever you look at a CT MRI x-ray exam they might go into
details for the doctor and then down at the bottom usually there'll be an
impression section which is a summary so here's the summary number one
decreased right breast massed right axillary axillaries are armpit added
up at the that's an enlargement and right injured chest wall nodule this is
consistent with response to therapy so they're just make the radiologist is
making a comment that it's decreasing because this person is doing some sort of
therapy right lower lobe nodule slightly decrease in size from prior
exam multiple new enlarging sclerotic densities and that's what the question
is found in the skeletal area likely representative healing anesthetic
disease once a sclerotic density so a sclerotic density is in so when bone
heals so if you have fracture so if you fractured your arm let's say and then
you took an x-ray right afterwards you'd see the break but then you took an x-ray
three weeks later you'd see a sclerotic density sclerosis sclerotic is a term used
for bone an increase in density an increase laydown of bone now it can be from a
fracture that's healing now eventually usually there won't be a sclerotic density
maybe six months post fracture healing because your body balanced that out so you
wouldn't see an extra density there but as it's healing you're gonna have an increase
in bone density there that's called sclerosis so if there is was metastatic
disease meaning cancer that had metastasized to a mold remember I said
when cancer metastasizes to the bone it's 99 percent of the time it's
a lytic lesion so lytic lesion is completely different than sclerotic lesion lesion just means
what we see there so something going on so a lytic lesion is a bone eating away it's
it's loss of bone density the sclerotic lesion is an increase in density so
when a cancer is healing so let's say there was a lytic lesion metastasis to the bone and it's
that that cancer is dying now your body's gonna heal that lesion with an increase in bone density
so when you see sclerotic densities sclerotic lesions sclerotic sites on the bone with a person that
has has had history and metastasis that's always a good thing so sclerosis on the bone is a good
if it's healing density now you're gonna get sclerosis in a joint that's not a good thing that
would be like in an arthritis situation so if I have bouldy arthritis let's say a
from use arthritis or what's called a degenerative arthritis also known as an osteoarthritis
I will have a sclerosis of the joint that's not good so you've got to increase
laid out a bouldy material in the joint joints are supposed to be enlarged and
movable when you have an increase in calcium laid out of the joint it's less movable
if you have more of a bone on bone type situation so when you see it in a bone
post metastasis that's a good thing when they measure a tumor on scans can they tell if there is
cancer under the tumor or is it just a shell no they typically can't unless the tumor is calcified
which typically it doesn't calcify there's some long tumors that will actually calcify
but most of the time it abreast or something like that it won't calcify so you know it's hard to say
you could have a pseudo enlargement we've spoken about that dozens of times when you look at a CT
scanner and MRI you know it's gold standard but it's far from gold standard truthfully because
you can get a pseudo enlargement it looks like it enlargement but it's actually an immune attack
to the cancer and you can't really tell what your measuring tumor markers are also decreasing so
that's great um very excited about the results thank you for your team thank you for all you're
done so you were very welcome give all the credit to god if he's healing you and he's using also it's
a ways to do that we're just you're so thankful for that this is why you look at multiple
markers so you don't just look at an x-ray you don't just look at a CT scan you don't just look at a
PET scanner an MRI or a blood test the more ways you can look at it including looking at subjective
findings you're going to have a better analysis of progress of disease